if you missed out on the division's  closed beta a couple weeks back you're  going to have another chance to check  out Ubisoft's online shooter the  publisher announced today that the  division will be getting an open beta  later this month xbox one players can  start exploring the rundown streets of  New York on februari 18 pc and  playstation 4 players on the other hand  can jump in on the action the following  day the beta ends for all platforms on  februari 21st Ubisoft also confirmed  that players can preload the beta  starting februari 16 if you played the  closed beta there's even a little  incentive to return the open beta will  include an extra story mission and if  you take part in it you'll receive a  special in-game reward once the full  game arrives the division hits shelves  on March 8 2016 will you give the beta  try let me know in the comments below  and for more on the division you're  already in the right place  you